avec le confinement le télétravail aussi
la ligne entre vie personnelle et
travail est de plus en plus floue du
rock'n roll
avec l'adoption de cette loi du droit à
la déconnexion l'ontario voulu en
quelque sorte et rétablir cet équilibre
ici au nord de toronto cette compagnie
familial construit notamment des
ascenseurs et du ciel et parfois les
communications se poursuivre au delà des
heures de travail pour les employés
[Musique]
youssef s'est dotée du vernis d'une
charte du droit à la déconnexion la
compagnie promet donc dans la mesure du
possible de ne pas contacter ses
employés hors des heures de bureau et
les encourage du même coup à stopper les
communications pendant cette même
période de temps à moins d'une urgence
[Musique]
avec cette politique l'ontario veut
faire d'une pierre deux coups offrir de
meilleures conditions travailleurs et
aussi en attirer plus pour s'attaquer au
problème de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
pour le propriétaire de you sell qui
était en déplacement lors de notre
passage ce ne sera pas suffisant pour
faire venir un nombre important de
travailleurs en construction dont
[Musique]
ici dans cette entreprise de marketing
numérique on espère que cette nouvelle
loi séduit les travailleurs d'ailleurs
qu'ils pourront ils y travaillent et
sont nécessairement déménager en ontario
et
le concept de droit à la déconnexion
fait son chemin depuis quelques années
en 2017 la france est devenue le premier
pays à se doter d'un droit à la
déconnexion dans son code du travail
l'absence de sanction fait toutefois en
sorte que les résultats sont peu
tangible pour le moment le portugal va
plus loin depuis l'année dernière il est
désormais interdit pour un patron de
contacter ses employés en dehors des
heures de travail faute de quoi une
amende de plus de 13 mille dollars
canadiens peut lui être imposée en
ontario si la loi du droit à la
déconnexion et provincial son contenu
lui et déterminés par chaque entreprise
ce qui pourrait faire en sorte que son
application soit très inégale ne la loi
encore est plus floue que ce fait achkar
étonné avocat qui accompagne les
entreprises dans la rédaction de leurs
politiques sur le droit à la déconnexion
oui
[Musique]
des inspecteurs du ministère du travail
auront la responsabilité de s'assurer
que tous les employeurs concernés se
soit dotée d'une politique du droit à la
déconnexion mais pour l'instant aucune
sanction n'est prévue
le droit à la déconnexion pourrait
s'étendre au reste du pays car un comité
consultatif se penche sur la question à
ottawa en attendant c'est en ontario que
le concept sera testé en premier